the gyro can experience is anybody ever
had a real feasible idea how to fix that
how to like take all these impoverished
in inner-city communities we know have
been crime ridden for decades and stop
it how do you stop it
what do you do what but what's the plan
how do you go in there how much money
would it take how much money would it
take to take all of the take one city
Detroit impoverished communities in
Detroit and bring it up how what would
you have to do how would you have to fix
this how would you have to have
community centers how much would it cost
to have counseling and guidance and a
positive community like foster a
positive community with people that are
like professional like psychologists and
health care workers and andanddan
doctors and people that can talk to kids
and tell them about potential careers
and things that they can do and that
there's ways out and then foster them in
the community programs that can get them
tutoring to give them a little bit of a
bump before they can go to college all
these different things that just don't
test it don't a lot of it don't exist
but it's got to start it has got to
start at home it has to run at home it
has to it has to because you can make
all the plans to programs you want
somebody has enforcement that they have
to enforce it a teacher can have the
best lesson plan and the best curriculum
of ever of she couldn't teacher of the
year whatever you know I'm saying but
what if she was she's teaching and what
she's trying to get them to understand
if it's not reinforced at home then it
goes nowhere right you know and it's
like the I don't even know how do you
address the mindset of parents or some
people aren't supposed to be parents but
that's where everything starts yeah well
everything starts there I think some
people it's a cycle right some people
had parents that were unqualified to
have them and then they became
unqualified to have their own parents
and whether or not the shooter shouldn't
be responsible we could all agree they
should be responsible they're not those
kids a lot of times the ones that get
[ __ ] over in life they get a bad start
yeah but if if there was some way some
way through some sort of a community
program to ensure that these kids always
had a place that felt like a community
felt like family they can go there it's
safe there's always somebody somebody
there they can handle them and take care
of but man my for those guys
really meant a you're [ __ ] their own
[ __ ] up man that's one thing they [ __ ]
their own [ __ ] up sometime man like
everything you're saying like Nipsey
Hussle the rabbit had passed away that
was well respected to hip-hop all of all
cross the boy he was an example of
everything that you're saying he was an
example of how to fix it
he was example of everything that you
said he was doing getting people up on
their finances he had a realty company
out of the UM the marathon clothing
shopping mall he had he employed people
that came out of prison people that
didn't have a fair shake in life you
don't say he donated to the community he
had kids and videos he was doing
everything he was trying to explain to
people how important is to have business
by property if you know where his store
was a train line is gonna come in soon
so all the property he brought around he
knew how much was gonna be worth then he
tried to pass that knowledge on to a lot
of people he passed it on through his
music he passed on how he lived his life
he passed on by his associations he gave
everything he didn't leave the [ __ ]
hood he stayed in the hood he built his
name in the hood he came from a place
where people's comparing him to Snoop
Dogg right out the gate
he's Snoop Dogg bah bah bah he had to
beat through that [ __ ] he's selling his
own [ __ ] he record his own he's doing
his own [ __ ]
he won't leave the [ __ ] hood he's
letting people see his life he's letting
people see his [ __ ] life and
with all that said in his parking lot in
his hood another [ __ ] shot him to death
and that's [ __ ] up that's type of [ __ ]
make me be frustrated about being black
sometimes goddamn [ __ ] and then you
wonder why people say this about you our
community needs to check [ __ ]
and get garbage and rodents and roaches
like that [ __ ]
out of here
as much as we trying to figure out the
problem as much as we could put a
million people in a [ __ ] room okay
this blah blah
man if [ __ ] don't stop [ __ ]
the own [ __ ] up you nobody ever gonna
[ __ ] care
[Applause]